alright let's get started why
vaynermedia what made you think well I
think he remembers it everybody was
weirded out that AJ and I started
vaynermedia because everybody was
building big tech apps what I knew was I
was building a foundation for my future
it wasn't hard for me the first 13 years
of my life weren't sexy
I was quiet and I built an actual
business I was twenty-two year old kid
and I worked everything we're building
businesses I used to work in a liquor
store from 7:00 in the morning to 10:00
at night for seven three years and the
only days off I took work to watch the
New York Jets you know I took over my
family business and was doing a couple
million dollars a year and over a
seven-year period I built it up to a 50
million dollar company turned 30 freaked
out and decided I wanted to do something
else 17 months I did yyb TV five days a
week I walked away from being filled my
company so everyone and welcome to
another episode why my regime media hook
Gary baby then was just that drive but I
just knew that I have to do something
different and
I wish all of you 13 16 19 and 24 year
olds to steal how young I am in my soul
right now it would change everything you
do you'd become dramatically more
patient which would mean that you would
make a lot more of the successes that
you want to happen most of you will lose
because you're trying to take shortcuts
slow and steady wins the race
you're only competing with yourself 25
that's it just keep doing it for five
years you'll be a young man and it'll be
their patience I mean it when I say
patient when I was 25 years old I
California book finish I don't
I recommend it very seriously that you
go home and think about that they should
probably allocate the next 21 years of
your life to try to execute on the thing
that you want to do for the body just
put in work and enjoy that enjoy your
[ __ ] and dirt and bleeding and the grind
and don't give a [ __ ] about what anybody
else thinks
why you haven't done it why are you
doing that have school done [ __ ]
Wendy's Walmart your side hustle work 21
you're 19 and you can serve seven full
years learning your path meaning people
that are Mentors
being patient and you wake up and you're
26 years old the entire life in front of
you and you've done great foundational
work
to go on and then you stay with the kind
and there are money at the time that was
my patient that was my good in that it's
a balance of regret and patience but you
can go hard up a three-year do nothing
right wake up and be young as [ __ ] I am
convinced that people do not understand
that it takes patience and a long time
though the business
[Music]
you